herr präsident meine damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ein jahr
leben wir jetzt mit dieser pandemie und
versuchen sie zu bekämpfen
ich sage deshalb versuchen weil wir
damit noch lange nicht am ende sind wir
haben aber im gegensatz zu vielen die
heute hier vor mir gesprochen haben uns
dennoch weiter entwickelt es ist nicht
so dass wir nicht ein jahr auch aus
dieser pandemie schon gelernt haben
wir haben impfstoffe wir haben mit dem
impfen begonnen mehr als zwei millionen
menschen sind schon geimpft das ist noch
lange nicht ausreichend das wissen wir
alle aber das sind wichtige schritte die
wir jetzt begonnen haben die korona app
ist vorhin angesprochen worden der
lindner hat gesagt sie ist eingeführten
hat sich überhaupt nicht
weiterentwickelt es stimmt nicht es hat
mehrere updates gegeben
ein kontakt tagebuch was gefordert wurde
ist jetzt drin wir haben aktuelle zahlen
drin aber ich sage auch ich sage auch da
ist noch luft nach oben keine frage
denn wenn wir über öffnungs strategien
reden kann die app natürlich auch wenn
man ins restaurant geht oder in
veranstaltungen zusätzlichen mehrwert
haben wenn man dann die kontakt
ermittlungen auch damit nutzt
datenschutzgerecht das ist möglich und
deshalb gibt es natürlich eine
weiterentwicklung an der stelle
und ich will auf diese öffnung strategie
und die perspektive gehen viele menschen
haben sich von dieser veranstaltung
gestern der kanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten eine perspektive
gewünscht wir alle wünschen uns eine
perspektive und die stufen pläne die
vorliegen das ist ja mittlerweile
nicht nur so dass einzelne die
vorgestellt haben es gibt einstufen
pläne die haben wir gestern hier im
parlament diskutiert aber es gibt auch
stufen plänen der länder
und natürlich haben wir uns gewünscht
dass dann nicht nur der bereich der
friseure für die branche freut es mich
aber dass nicht nur dass dabei rauskommt
das ist durchaus ein punkt wo wir
perspektiven geben müssen aber ich sage
auch perspektive zu geben es nicht so
einfach wenn wir nicht wissen wie die
mutationen das ist ein
wissenschaftlicher begriff auch wenn der
a steht dieser begriff schwerfällt
mutationen sich unterschwellig
ausbreiten dann ist es ein großes
problem dass wir nicht wissen was eine
richtige zahl für eine perspektive oder
eine eröffnungs strategie ist und das
treibt uns ja alle um
ich würde gerne sofort alles auf aber
ich würde auch gern sofort ein
stufenplan beschließen wobei die die
vorliegen ja auch schon sehr
unterschiedlich sind
aber wir müssen uns doch klar machen
dass wir eben nicht wissen wie die
ausbreitungen weitergehen wird und ich
will noch mal daran erinnern das kommt
mir hier zu kurz vor einer debatte
wir waren im sommer soweit wir haben
alle schulen auf gemacht gab
präsenzunterricht alle lokale alle
kulturen haben wie der erste
veranstaltung macht es gab hygiene und
konzepte und trotzdem sind uns die
infektionszahlen entglitten so und die
sind uns endgeräten im oktober
erschossen sie hoch das wissen wir doch
gar nicht ob sich im sommer war das
liegt einfach daran wenn zu viele
kontakte möglich sind hat das virus die
chance sich auszubreiten und wenn
mutationen dazu kommen die sind normal
dass sie dazu kommen wenn die aber dazu
dazu kommen dass sie möglicherweise
impfstoffe die wir jetzt haben unmöglich
machen oder dass wir erst wieder zeit
brauchen sie zu verändern
dann stehen wir in der nächsten
in den nächsten drei monaten wieder an
einem punkt wo wir wieder alles zu
machen müssen und ich sollte man das
schadet kindern und eltern genauso unter
uns ein dieses auf und ab das ist doch
das große problem
und jetzt zu sagen wir machen jetzt
schöne stufen pläne alles super aber wir
dürfen trotzdem nicht vergessen es muss
irgendwelche zahlen seien an die man
eine perspektive dann auch knüpft und
natürlich müssen wir an der stelle wenn
es jetzt zum beispiel seit sommer gibt
es bessere schnelltests demnächst kommen
selbst test- und heimtest dann muss man
das auch an eine strategie binden und
die fehlten übrigens auch ich möchte
auch dass selbst dazugehören dass sich
heinz zu hause mache wenn sie eine gute
qualität haben aber doch nicht einfach
nur so wie sie auf dem markt sondern es
muss doch verbunden sei mit einer
perspektive für kulturschaffende für
öffnung von restaurants für kneipen für
alles mögliche dafür muss doch auch so
eine test strategie weiterentwickelt
werden und das gehört dazu für mich zu
einem stufenplan und daran muss
gearbeitet werden und dass wir jetzt die
schulen und kitas wieder in die
verantwortung der länder gegeben haben
ja das ist föderalismus und sie sind
dafür zuständig es macht mir trotzdem
sorgen das will ich hier ganz ernsthaft
sagen weil ich nicht weiß wie die
einzelnen länder damit umgehen werden
das wird unterschiedlich sein und in
nordrhein westfalen das ist das
bundesland wo ich herkomme war das
bisher nicht besonders glücklich wie man
die schulen darauf vorbereitet hat wie
sie damit umgehen sollen mit präsenz
wechsel unterricht kreative ideen wurden
kreative ideen idm berliner wurden da
unterdrückte nordrhein westfalen so und
das ist doch ein punkt wo man wo man
sagt ja das mache ich mir sorgen sie
preisen
den föderalismus an ich habe da große
sorgen dass nicht andere länder im
vergleich des bundesgebietes wieder
abgehangen werden dass nicht genug
nachhilfe stattfindet dass man nicht gut
genug vorbereitet ist auf die öffnung
ich habe großes vertrauen dass die
länder schaffen
ich will nur meine sorge sagen dass das
es jetzt auch gut vorbereitet werden
soll dass die schulen das jetzt gut
vorbereiten dass die länder das uns
vorbereiten und erst dann sollten
schritt für schritt geöffnet werden das
ist mein appell nochmal in die richtung
auch derer die jetzt die verantwortung
dafür übernommen haben das ist wichtig
für schülerinnen und schüler für
lehrerinnen und lehrer
das hat auch dass das auch so
funktioniert dass wir alle damit auch
sicher umgehen können und die
infektionszahlen so niedrig bleiben wie
bisher das ist ein erfolg den wir
durchaus heute auch noch mal sagen durch
die zahlen gehen kontinuierlich runter
und ich wünsche mir dass es weiterhin
nach unten geht denn damit ist uns allen
geholfen herzlichen dank hinderte hat
das wünschen wir uns sicherlich alle
dass die zahlen möglichst bald und
schnell da unten gehen doch wie und wie
lange halten wir das aus die
bundeskanzlerin hat gestern definiert
dass die zahl unter 35 sinken muss viele
sind der meinung man kann mit stufen
plänen auch nicht mehr hören werden kann
setzen völlig unbekannt ist die
auswirkung der britischen mutation den
ich erinner jetzt sebastian münzenmaier
für die herr präsident meine damen und
herren die folgen von angst können weit
größer sein als die durch das virus
selbst mit diesen worten eröffnete jens
spahn am 4 märz 2020 eine
bundestagsdebatte zum corona virus und
heute sind seine worte treffen der denn
je diese bundesregierung versetzt
vorsätzlich ein ganzes volk in angst
meinungsvielfalt ist im umfeld der
kanzlerin nicht erwünscht
stattdessen sollen merkels haus und hof
wissenschaftler posten wieder oder
bringt man politisch gewollte panikmache
möglichst wissenschaftlich an hauchen
der inzidenz wert von 50 war noch nie
wirklich wissenschaftlich begründet und
jetzt über nacht einfach mal so auf 35
gesenkt was machen wir denn eigentlich
im märz liebe frau bundeskanzlerin wenn
wir uns eben geliebten incidents wird
dann wie
angenähert haben wird dann eine neue
zahl gewürfelt oder entdecken sie
irgendeine neue noch schlimmere noch
tödlicher noch aggressivere mutation aus
papua neuguinea oder sonstwo auf der
welt
ich bin mir sicher in ihrem lockdown
fetischismus fällt ihnen irgendetwas 1
ihre devise lautet koste es was es wolle
dieser lockdown muss unbedingt bleiben
es gibt es gibt mittlerweile zahlreiche
namhafte wissenschaftler biologen dient
studien die wirksamkeit eines londons
anzweifeln es gibt alternativ vorschläge
beispielsweise aus uns noch fraktionen
die einen kurswechsel und einen besseren
schutz der risikogruppen fordern es gibt
zahlreiche kritische stimmen die den
sogenannten kollateralschaden ihrer
politik kann man aber was soll's angela
merkel verschanzt sich weiterhin mit
ihrem ministerpräsidenten stammtisch im
kanzleramt und während bodo ramelow kann
die kraft sorgt verzogen sie liebe frau
bundeskanzlerin die zukunft eines ganzen
landes meine damen und herren
betrachten wir doch mal die harten
fakten
es gibt momentan 164.000 am corona virus
infiziert in ganz deutschland dazu
zählen auch die sogenannten symptomlos
erkrankten früher nannte man das wohl
gesund aber selbst wenn ich jetzt ihrer
logik folge und diese infizierten zahlen
betrachtet dann sprechen wir über 01 97
prozent der menschen in deutschland die
infizierte 0,197 prozent währenddessen
sind aber knapp zehn prozent der
menschen in deutschland arbeitslos oder
in kurzarbeit tendenz eher steigend
hunderttausende von selbstständigen
künstlern und freiberuflern stehen kurz
vor dem ruin
die insolvenzwelle rollt noch auf uns zu
und wird nicht nur tausende kleine und
mittelständische betriebe unter sich
begraben
sie wird auch die strukturen die
innenstädte unseres landes verändern
der mittelstand hat deutschland einst
groß gemacht aber der mittelstand wird
von dieser bundesregierung sehenden
auges an die wand gefahren meine damen
und herren
aber sie verzocken ja nicht nur den
wohlstand unserer
landes sondern auch die zukunft unserer
kinder in der aktuellen kurs die studie
klagen 85 prozent der befragten kinder
über eine seelische belastung die sorgen
und ängsten zugenommen auch depressive
symptome sind verstärkt zu beobachten
und vom bildungs verlust dank
geschlossener schulen spreche ich noch
gar nicht
liebe frau bundeskanzlerin was sie
anrichten wird unser land auf jahrzehnte
beschädigen
aber statt nach lösungen zu suchen wird
von dieser regierung einfach panik
geschürt
haben sie sich mal die wortwahl von
merkels entourage pünktlich vor den
regelmäßigen klänge runden angeschaut
da wird mit übertreibungen um sich
geworfen die der geneigte hörer er aus
hollywood film mit untergangsszenarien
kennt der dirigent des panikorchesters
karl lauterbach warnt vor dem turbo
virus eher kg chef lothar wieder spricht
davon dass das virus einen boost
erhalten habe und dino polizistin
melanie brinkmann beklagt ich zitiere
die mutante aus großbritannien und
andere werden uns überrennen
das virus hat einen raketenantrieb
bekommen es geht nur noch darum können
wir den siegeszug der varianten
hinauszögern und zeitgewinn zitat ende
diese dumpfe kriegs rhetorik erinnert an
dunkle zeiten und ich kann ihnen nur
zurufen stoppen sie endlich diese
panikmache schützen sie die
risikogruppen und beenden sie den lock
down some der unverhältnismässigen
folgen meine damen und herren unsere
fdp-fraktion kämpft mittlerweile seit
monaten mit hilfe von klugen ideen
anträgen und vorschlägen für eine
politik der vernunft und vor allem der
verhältnismäßigkeit wir wehren uns gegen
ihren wahnsinn und wir werden auch
weiterhin hier im bundestag alles dafür
tun unsere leute und unser land
verlieren ihren ideen zu schützen
aber leider sind uns teilweise die hände
gebunden weil die vereinte altparteien
front von den tiefroten sed-erben bis
hin zu den gelben wände hensen diese
kanzlerin stützt und dieses land immer
weiter richtung abgrund führt deshalb
möchte ich sie meine damen und herren an
den bildschirm da draußen direkt
ansprechen
wir brauchen ihre unterstützung wenn sie
in diesem land wirklich etwas ändern
wollen dann wählen sie die einzige
echte oppositionspartei und vierzehnter
märz können sie sich in rheinland-pfalz
und in baden-württemberg für freiheit
und vernunft anstatt für angst und
aktionismus entscheiden ich danke ihnen
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
davon sind offen
alexander dobrindt cdu/csu ist der
nächste redner
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ja in den
letzten wochen hat man das deutlich
gespürt dass jeder tag des verzichts
jeder tag der kontakt beschränkungen
jeder tag des schließens verlangt den
menschen und der wirtschaft in unserem
land unglaublich viel ab und gerade auch
in diesen letzten tagen und wochen hat
man festgestellt dass ein wunsch ja
immer stärker wird in unserer
gesellschaft der wunsch nach normalität
und genau das ist auch der grund warum
wir uns gerade in einer der kritischsten
phase nach der pandemie befinden weil
wir auf der einen seite die situation
haben dass der virus an einer
weggabelung steht bei der noch nicht
absehbar ist welchen weg er geht und den
von uns erhofften die insolvenzen weiter
runter oder einen anderen mit steigenden
insolvenzen durch die mutation und auf
der anderen seite stellen wir fest dass
die wirtschaftlichen die sozialen folgen
des lok bei uns deutlich auf die
stimmung sich auswirkungen die stimmung
angespannter wird bedrückender und ja
auch das muss man sagen bei einigen
begegnungen kann man das inzwischen ganz
persönlich feststellen ob das friseure
oder einzelhändler oder andere sind es
gibt auch eine stimmung die verzweifelte
wird und darauf muss die politik
reagieren und die reaktion heißt
konsequent und perspektiven miteinander
verbinden und dass es die auftrag und
die aufgabe und das ist auch das was in
unserer entscheidung von gestern
vorkommt wir haben klare perspektiven
gegeben für wirtschaftshilfen für
impfungen aber auch eine klare
perspektive für den einstieg in den
ausstieg aus dem block da meine damen
und herren
die beschlüsse von gestern
sie versuchen das grundprinzip von
konsequenz und perspektiven gelegen so
bringt die stellen sie eine
zwischenfrage nein danke bieten es gibt
momentan an der stelle auch eine ganze
reihe von fragen und auch kritikern der
zahl die gestern so eine große rolle
gespielt hat nämlich die inzidenz zahl
von 35
und da ist auch der hinweis ganz offen
gesprochen dass es sich um eine zahl
handelt die ja bereits im
infektionsschutzgesetz sich befindet was
stimmt ist für viele als erklärung nicht
ganz ausreichend und es wird auch heute
klar man trägt so sehr stark nach dieser
zahl von 50 die man aus den vergangenen
wochen und monaten sehr gut kennt und
deswegen hier noch einen satz auch zur
klaren erklärung dazu die 50 war immer
die zahl wo man bei wachsender infektion
den einstieg in den lockdown gewählt hat
sie kann nicht gleichzeitig die zahl des
ausstiegs aus dem lot down sein
ansonsten hätten wir einen andauernden
achterbahn effekt eine berg und talfahrt
zwischen locker und lockerungen und
deswegen muss die zahl der lockerungen
deutlich unter der 50 liegen damit wir
unsere erfolge an der stelle nicht
verspielen meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
wir haben festgestellt dass der druck
auf die forderung oder die forderung und
der druck dazu auf die öffnung der
schulen sehr sehr groß geworden ist und
ich hoffe dass diese maßnahme die die
länder an der stelle ergreifen jetzt der
entwicklung der senkung der infektions
kurve nicht zu sehr entgegen wirken ich
verstehe dass der druck groß ich
verstehe das home-office kinderbetreuung
und homeschooling eine enorme
doppelbelastung auch für die familien
bedeutet aber ich habe zweifel dass
diese maßnahme der schuleröffnung zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt eine richtige ist
unabhängig davon wie man diese frage
beantwortet steht für mich auf jeden
fall fest wir müssen alles daran setzen
dass diese maßnahmen nicht weitere
perspektiven der öffnungen der
wirtschaft verbaut meine damen und
herren das ist der auftrag jetzt auch
wenn man diese maßnahmen redet bei den
wirtschafts hilfen es ist richtig und
gut dass diese wirtschaft hilfe 3 jetzt
anlaufen beantragt werden können es ist
wichtig dass jetzt schnell und
unbürokratisch dann auch zur
abschlagszahlungen führen und wir werden
das auch feststellen wie schnell diese
abschlagszahlungen dann auch laufen ich
weise aber darauf hin es geht bei ganz
ganz vielen auch gerade bei den
selbstständigen bei denjenigen die ein
geschäft betreiben es geht bei ganz ganz
vielen um ein lebenswerk und deswegen
sind die emotionen auch ganz besonders
groß an dieser stelle und es wird am
ende konstellationen geben die auch
durch dieses raster der
überbrückungshilfe drei möglicherweise
durchfallen
deswegen mache dringende bitte auch an
den finanzminister
wir erwarten dass es auch einen
härtefall gibt herr finanzminister der
dann da stützt wo lebenswerke auf dem
spiel stehen und wo die algorithmen der
überbrückungshilfe nicht greifen auch
das ist eine notwendige maßnahme und die
wirtschaft an dieser stelle zu stärken
wer was ist betont worden dass impfen
ist der weg aus der krise um die
ansteckungen zu verringern um schwere
krankheitsverläufe einzudämmen und
todesfälle auch zu vermeiden es ist der
weg in das normale leben zurück und ja
auch da hat es fehler gegeben
das hatte fehlleistungen und
fehleinschätzungen auch gerade in
brüssel auch in der kommission gegeben
aber es hat auch eine verfehlte debatte
in deutschland gegeben eine
fehlgeleitete platte über den
sogenannten emv nationalismus meine
damen und herren wir brauchen keine
debatte über im nationalismus wir
brauchen eine debatte über mut zur
souveränität bei der frage der
versorgung von medikamenten und
impfstoffen das ist die aufgabe unserer
debatte und sehr geehrter herr bartsch
sie haben wahrscheinlich keine zeit bei
dieser diskussion zu folgen
trotzdem sei ihnen der seite hinweis an
der stelle gestattet sie haben hier als
erstes in einer art bewunderung
gegenüber den usa
diese als gelungenes beispiel beim
impfen beschrieben dann aber beklagt
dass der globale süden zu wenig
impfstoff hat sie müssen sich an der
stelle mal entscheiden weil abgesehen
davon dass die bewunderung für die usa
von ihrer seite ein vorgang an sich ist
die usa hat beim impfen eine ganz ganz
klare devise
und die heißt america
first und die wird sogar noch mit
kriegsrecht durchgesetzt dass sie das
bewundert das ist in der tat ein vorgang
wir brauchen eine souveränitäts
offensive auch im bereich der impfstoffe
der medikamentenversorgung der
bundesfinanzminister sieht man am
wochenende gesagt ich will das wieder
dass wir wieder die apotheke der welt
werden ich stimme ihnen da ausdrücklich
zu aber dann müssen auch die notwendigen
finanzmittel zur verfügung gestellt
werden um das zu erreichen
dann muss ein souveränitäts programm für
impfstoff und für medikamente forschung
und produktion in deutschland und europa
eingerichtet werden stellen sie dieses
programm vor und dann haben sie unsere
unterstützung herzlichen dank der
bundestag debattiert nach der
regierungserklärung der bundeskanzlerin
die gestern bekämpfung und die nächste
rednerin kommt von der cdu/csu nadine
schön sie stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende
noch nie in den ganzen wochen und
monaten der krise lagen die nerven so
plank ich denke das spüren wir alle
gerade die familien sind wirklich am
limit und vieles sagen wir können nicht
mehr
er könne nicht mehr das sagen die eltern
die roms kollegen kinderbetreuung
vereinbaren müssen mit der arbeit klar
es gibt den lohnersatz aber viele fühlen
sich auch ihren kolleginnen und kollegen
verpflichtet oder arbeiten selbst ins
system solle manchen berufe als lehrerin
als lehrer als pflegekräfte
wir können nicht mehr das sagen auch
sogar kinder die gerne wieder ihre
freundinnen freunde sehen würden die
gerne wieder mit anderen lernen würden
die gerne andere treffen und das gefühl
haben sich adäquat auf ihre prüfungen
vorbereiten zu können
und wir können nicht mehr sagen noch
ganz viele alleinstehende ob jung oder
alt die sagen ich kann nicht mal meine
beste freundin in den arm nehmen das
fehlt mir so sehr wie gerne würde man
jetzt sagen schluss jetzt wir haben
genug es reicht der wunsch nach einem
normalen oder einem normalen laden leben
er ist so kloos und deshalb ist es
wichtig dass auch gestern über
perspektiven gesprochen wurde und dass
wir hoffnung haben aber hoffnung macht
nur dann sinn wenn sie nicht direkt
wieder enttäuscht wird und perspektiven
sind nur dann gut wenn sie wirklich
tragfähig sind
und leider ist das virus noch da und bei
manchen reden heute in der debatte habe
ich mich gefragt in welcher welt leben
sie denn das virus ist noch da wir haben
kein lineares wir haben grundsätzlich
wächst dass wir das exponentiell
können froh sein dass die zahlen geht es
endlich nach unten gehen und das können
wir doch nicht verspielen
und ich erinnere mich noch sehr gut als
er im november den lock down als gemacht
haben und dachten mit hygiene konzept in
maske und abstand kommen weil er
irgendwie gut durch und die wahrheit war
das hat nicht geklappt die zahlen sind
gestiegen ich erinnere mich noch gut als
wir im dezember nachrichten aus sachsen
hatten wo es hieß dass in krankenhäusern
überkritisch nachgedacht nachgedacht
wird und ich erinnere mich an die panik
der menschen die dann bei steigenden
infektionszahlen sagen wir haben angst
um unsere angehörigen die vorbelastet
sind die noch nicht geimpft sind wir
haben angst dass das virus um sich
greift jahren als auffordern
folgeschäden
darüber wird auch gar nicht gesprochen
und deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir die
zahlen nach unten bringen und dass wir
die öffnung erst dann machen wenn wir
einen sockel wert erreicht haben der
nicht dazu führt dass die zahlen danach
gleich wieder explodieren
und es ist richtig das sage ich als
familienpolitikerin dass wir mit den
familien zuerst anfangen das wäre mit
den kindergärten den kitas und schulen
zuerst anfangen
aber auch hier gilt mit system und mit
verstand und so das test konzepte
vorliegen bevor man öffnet es reicht
nicht wenn sie nur auf dem papier da
sind und es reicht auch nicht lieber
frage wenn sie sagen es gibt bald alten
tipps noch gibt es die eigenen tests
nicht und deshalb müssen die kommunen
test konzepte schaffen damit wir die
schulen so öffnen können
das wird von dort keine gefahr ausgeht
für die schülerinnen und schüler selbst
wie ihre eltern
ihre angehörigen für uns alle und das
ist hart und es ist noch ein bisschen
arbeit aber ich traue den kommunen nicht
schaut den ländern nicht den schulen zu
dass sie das schaffen
und es ist ja so viel geschafft worden
schauen sie doch was in den schulen
schon passiert da wird auch mein
herzlicher dank mal an die lehrerinnen
und lehrer was die möglich gemacht haben
in den letzten wochen und monaten
das ist doch wahnsinn da wird sich
gekümmert und jeden einen schulleiter
werten digitale konzepte geschaffen und
mein appell ist auch kalender ich habe
es nicht verstanden dass ihre fdp
kultusministerin in nrw am sagte bei
einer schule die sagte wir können breed
arbeiten dass das das nicht möglich war
lassen wir doch die individuellen
konzepte vor ort zu lassen wir doch die
kreativität der menschen auch ihren
entfaltungsspielraum und dann finden wir
doch viel bessere lösung und deshalb
ihre kollegen kollegen
es ist gut dass wir mit den schulen
anfang wir müssen die kinder in den
blick nehmen denn es geht auch um
pädagogische und soziale folgen aber mit
sinn und verstand dafür abonniert ich
dass es unsere aufgabe in den nächsten
monaten den nächsten wochen vielen dank
so nadine schön hatten wir noch mal
zwischenbemerkung vielen dank herr
präsident
dobrindt beziehen sie hatten sehr viel
zu es war mein fehler dass ich ihnen die
vorher nicht die zwischen gegeben ein
gedanke dass es dass es jetzt
funktioniert da ich doch sehr gern zum
kollegen dobrindt sprechen wollte sie
hatten die wirtschaftshilfen
angesprochen und es stimmt ja dass bei
den november dezember hilfen haben
einige betriebe profitiert es gibt
allerdings auch betriebe die haben noch
keinen einzigen cent gesehen und es sind
des schmerzmittels oberfranken nun als
bayerin besonders und sie als bayer
sicher auch ausgerechnet brauerei
gaststätten ihr einziges vergehen ist
sie braun selbst bier teilweise seit
jahrhunderten und schenken das in ihrer
gaststätte aus deswegen bekommen sie als
misch betriebe
keine hilfen es gebe eine ganz einfache
lösung für dieses problem sie stellen
die brauereigaststätte mit anderen
gaststätten gleich es geht um ganz ganz
wenige betriebe und ich rede jetzt nicht
von überbrückungshilfe drei sondern ich
rede von der jetzigen situation diese
betriebe sind jetzt in not daher meine
frage an sie schaffen sie es als
koalition noch diese änderung hin zu
kriegen oder lassen sie die betriebe den
bach runter gehen möchten sie antworten
sie haben das wort
sehr geehrte frau kollegin warum sorgt
hier für ein bisschen heiterkeit dass
sie sich für brauereien einsätze nicht
alle das ausdrücklich nicht ich sage es
ganz deutlich dass es sich hier um ein
thema handelt bei dem
nachbesserungsbedarf besteht wir haben
festgestellt dass im bereich der
mischbetrieb es hier zu einer
nachteiligen behandlung von brauereien
gaststätten kommt damit auch zu einer
nachteiligen behandlung von
traditionsbetriebe die oftmals seit
jahrzehnten oder vielleicht schon seit
jahrhunderten unterwegs sind wir wollen
genau dieses thema lösen
deswegen sind wir in intensiven debatten
mit dem wirtschaft und dem
finanzministerium dazu da für eine
adäquate lösung zu finden ich halte das
ausdrücklich für geboten vielen dank
jetzt hat das wort die kollegin sabine
dittmar spd und dabei wollte ich an der
stellung man hat ihnen schön loben die
nämlich als erste rednerin noch einmal
gesagt hat welche bemühungen sich die
schulen gemacht haben und wie viel
engagement dar eingeflossen ist und dass
man mal gelobt hat jetzt also sabine
dittmer die gesundheitspolitische
sprecherin der spd heute morgen schon im
phoenix-interview zu hören der offenbart
noch einmal eindrücklich das enorme
spannungsverhältnis mit dem wir alle in
diesen tagen und wochen zurechtkommen
müssen wir sehen einerseits dass unsere
gemeinsamen anstrengungen der
zurückliegenden wochen ihre wirkung
zeichen die zu jahresbeginn festgelegten
verstärkten maßnahmen zu kontakt
beschränkung waren richtig es ist uns
damit gelungen die zahl der
neuinfektionen mit dem corona wir uns
deutlich zu reduzieren
in fast allen bundesländern liegen wir
heute bei einer inzidenz von deutlich
unter 100 neuinfektionen pro
hunderttausend einfordern
trotzdem sind die todesfälle noch viel
zu hoch und noch immer arbeiten die
intensivstationen an bzw
oftmals noch über die belastungsgrenze
da die patienten zahlen nur langsam
zurückgehen
meine damen und herren die gegenwärtige
situation und die schutzmaßnahmen
verlangen uns allen privat beruflich
sozial und ökonomisch viel ab und auch
wenn wir alle irgendwie genervt sind und
ein ende des lockouts herbeisehnen zeigt
der jüngste deutschland brennt nach wie
vor eine 75 prozentige zustimmung zu den
maßnahmen die meisten wissen
die beste waffe gegen das virus ist in
keinerlei chance zu geben sich zu
verbreiten und dafür dass die
überwiegende mehrheit diesen weg
solidarisch mitglied möchte ich nicht
ganz ausdrücklich bedanken
gemeinsamen die mainzer machen wir
schritt für schritt boden gut in
kräftigen wir sehen deutliche
fortschritte zum beispiel bei den
impfungen elf monate nach dem ersten
fall in deutschland konnten wir mit dem
impfen beginn das ist eine herausragende
leistung unserer wissenschaft ein
großteil der bewohnerinnen und bewohner
der senioren- und pflegeeinrichtungen
als eine besonders gefährdete
personengruppen hat mittlerweile die
erstimpfung und zum teil auch die zeit
linke erhalten und es ist gut dass sich
bund und länder ergänzen zur nationalen
teams strategie auf einen hilfsplan
verständigt haben die
impfstoffversorgung ist klar sein
planbarkeit ist der schlüssel zum erfolg
und wir werden in deutschland in den
kommenden wochen deutlich mehr impfstoff
zur verfügung haben und da muss
sichergestellt sein dass dieser
impfstoff dann auch zügig in den
bundesländern verengt wird und deshalb
ist es gut dass sich die konferenz
gestern auch mit diesen
organisationsfragen beschäftigt hat wir
sehen für seenforschung beim testen die
laborkapazitäten beim pc atteste
zwischenzeitlich auf über zwei millionen
ausgebaut eine wahnsinnsleistung unsere
labore und auch die anti den schnelltest
sind mittlerweile ein fester bestandteil
in vielen einrichtungen
sie ermöglichen ein wichtiges stück an
mehr teilhabe und sobald die anti den
schnelltest nach dem notwendigen
prüfungen durch das bundesamt für
arzneimittel auch für die
selbstanwendung zugelassen sind werden
wir einen weiteren wichtigen baustein
zur verfügung haben der die test
strategie sinnvoll ergänzen wird das
alles sind gute nachrichten
und genau hier zeigt sich aber der
ambivalenz und frau derzeitigen
situation ja wir haben boden gut gemacht
aber trotzdem sind wir noch lange nicht
am ziel
vor allem die verbreitung der virus
mutationen brasilianische
südafrikanische britische bereiten große
sorgen dass die britische variante b 11
7 verbreitet sich rasant
in deutschland sie ist sehr viel
infektiöse und aggressiver als der wild
virus und auch wenn unsere neue
infektionen insgesamt deutlich sinken
müssen wir doch zur kenntnis nehmen dass
sich der andere der mutationen darum wer
im zweistelligen prozentbereich vermehrt
und das bedeutet im klartext dass jedes
geringsten nachlass gegen die kontakt
beschränkungen
denn videos ein exponentielles wachstum
ermöglicht und diese chance meine damen
und herren dürfen wir ihn auf keinen
fall geben
und deshalb ist es wichtig dass die
bundesländer es dann verabredet haben
erst bei einer stabilen sieben tage in
stands von 35 weitere eröffnungen zu
ermöglichen und dennoch sage ich hier
auch ich bedauere ist dass es der
kanzlerin und den ländervertretern nicht
gelungen ist zum einen im
bildungsbereich für mehr einheitlichkeit
zu erreichen und zum anderen zu einem
konkreten fahrplan natürlich immer
orientiert am infektionsgeschehen sich
darauf zu verabreden
wir brauchen eine belastbare strategie
die den bürgerinnen und bürgern in
unternehmen der gastronomie den
kulturschaffenden klare und transparente
planungs perspektiven gibt und zwar
sowohl für den fall einer verbesserung
der lage als auch für den fall dass das
infektionsgeschehen sich erneut
verschlechtert
meine damen und herren liebe bürgerinnen
und bürger der erde kollegen wir haben
noch einen langen weg vor uns aber
schrittweise kommen wir weiter wenn wir
alle bereit sind mitzuhelfen bei
lockerungen diszipliniert sind bei
kurzfristigen anstiegen uns wieder
zurücknehmen
lassen sie uns diesen weg weiterhin
gemeinsam und solidarisch gehen und
corona die stirn bieten bleiben sie
gesund sagt die gesundheitspolitische
sprecherin der spd in der tat die
solidarität ist wichtig auch die
erkenntnis natürlich und man muss die
menschen mitnehmen sie jetzt
angesprochen die mehrzahl der menschen
ist nach wie vor bereit
diesen virus zu trotzen in dem man auf
freiheitsrechte einschränkt aber die
politiker müssen dass wirklich jedes mal
gut erklären andreas jung jetzt der
schäferin fraktionsvorsitzender der cdu
es ist der ort an dem über diese
maßnahmen diskutiert wird und diskutiert
werden muss und hier muss auch
gestritten werden
das gehört bei einer solchen debatte
dazu hier wird auch entschieden wir
haben das mit grundlegenden entscheidung
zu allen schritten auch getan ralph
brinkhaus hingewiesen auch das
infektionsschutzgesetz ich will aber
doch und gerade wenn sie mir das zu
rufen auch in ihre richtung sagen man
kann über vieles streiten aber über
bestimmte fakten eben nicht dass wir in
dieser schweren situation sind im land
das liegt nicht an der politik das liegt
daran dass ein virus weltweit in einer
weltweiten pandemie über uns gekommen
ist dass wir länger in einer schwierigen
situation sind liegt daran dass sich
eine mutation des sich mutationen
gebildet haben das ist das was ich
beschwer was uns beschwer macht und dann
kann man darüber diskutieren und
streiten wie man darauf reagiert ab
bietet verwechseln sie nicht ursache und
wirkung
und zweitens ich erinnere mich dass es
der london begonnen wurde wir ähnliche
debatten in diesem haus hatten kann man
auch jetzt über vieles diskutieren aber
nicht darüber dass es in einer anderen
situation sind als im dezember
die situation ist besser geworden die
zahlen sind runter gegangen deshalb sind
wir jetzt in einer situation in der wir
auch wieder über die nächsten schritte
zur lockerung sprechen können weil
maßnahmen konsequent umgesetzt würden
weil die bürgerinnen und bürger in ihrer
ganz großen mehrheit mit akzeptanz und
mit vorsicht diese maßnahmen umsetzen
und manches auch darüber hinaus auch
daran kann kein zweifel sein wir sind in
einer besseren
situation ich will drittens sagen ja wir
können diskutieren und streiten und
unterschiedliche vorstellungen haben
aber ich möchte doch hier nochmal für
uns alle betonen diese entscheidungen
die jetzt notwendig sind die trifft
niemand leichtfertig die kanzlerin hat
gesagt es gibt keinen tag an dem sie an
dem uns die existenzsorgen nicht um
tragen der betriebe an dem uns auch die
situation in den familien nicht umtreibt
das ist glaube ich etwas was wir in
aller deutlichkeit betonen müssen und
worauf wir antworten geben müssen und
ich bin froh dass gestern genau diese
dinge in diesem beschluss auch sich
wiederfinden was die familien angeht da
ist jetzt eine diskussion beim können
kitas und grundschulen geöffnet werden
aber es wird festgehalten und einem
breiten konsens
es gibt eine priorität wenn wir öffnen
werden kann
dann sollen kitas kindergärten schulen
die ersten sein diese priorität drückt
sich auch aus in der empfehlung in der
förderung die im freien folge so zu
verändern dass erzieherinnen und
erzieher des grundschullehrern und
grundschullehrer hoch gewertet worden
und es ist der konkret der ausdruck des
respekts dass wir haben von den
leistungen die diese menschen für unsere
gesellschaft in diesen tagen bringen
wirtschafts hilfen der länder ist es
glaube ich nicht mehr da vielleicht
liest er gerade denn die ergebnisse des
koalitionsausschusses nach dann hätte er
gewusst hat er den verlust drückt
angesprochen ist ja nicht so im handel
sie wissen doch dass beschlossen wurde
den rücktritt von fünf millionen auf
zehn millionen euro zu erhöhen
für ein ja dadurch genau sie kennen ja
die regelung und ich bin ich verstehe
dass sie sagen das kann noch mehr werden
das ist ja in ordnung aber es ist eine
verdopplung es sind fünf millionen euro
mehr die zurückgetragen werden können
als zuvor und es ist sich nicht sondern
ist ein wichtiger schritt genau so wie
es eine wichtige nachricht ist dass die
überbrückungshilfen drei jetzt beantragt
werden können und wir setzen darauf dass
die abschlagszahlung die es möglich sind
bis zu einer höhe von 100.000 euro was
auch ein möglicher ein wichtiger schritt
ist dass das ausgeschöpft wird dass es
schnell geht dass die länder die er die
auszahlung machen
mit derselben intensität mit stärkerer
intensität wir als bisher daran gehen
die hilfen müssen schnell sein
sie müssen ausgeweitet werden das
passiert beim verlust drückt und sie
müssen noch besser abgestimmt werden und
deshalb ist es wichtig dass jetzt
mitgeteilt wurde dass die kfw das
kooperationsverbot aufhebt es
entschieden worden zu recht im november
dass auch kleine betriebe die schnell
kredite haben können aber ein kleiner
betrieb der von anderen kredit hatte der
hat es nicht bekommen dass es ist
aufgehoben alle betriebe in deutschland
krimis die schnell kredite bekommen
das sind drei beispiele die dafür stehen
dass die hilfen verbessern wurden wir
müssen wenn die krise länger geht dieses
netz diesen instrumentenkasten weiter
ausbauen
darauf drängen wir und darauf arbeiten
wir hin das sind wichtige maßnahmen auf
den weg gebracht werden wir bleiben dran
haben sie noch eine zwischenfrage das
leben
otto fricke von der fdp dann würde ich
gerne von ihnen wissen was ich sagen das
ist jetzt gefordert doppelung habe ich
sie entweder so verstanden diese
verdoppelung reicht jetzt aus oder habe
ich sie so verstanden dass es in der
koalition weitere überlegungen dazu gibt
hier auf den schon ursprünglich seit
mehreren monaten vorgesehen den
fdp-vorschlag zuzugeben wo ist da die
position ist das der punkt den sie jetzt
erreicht haben und für ausreichend
halten oder kommt da seitens der
koalition noch mehr
es ist ein wichtiger schritt in den
fraktionsvorsitz vorher vergessen zu
erwähnen
und ich wollte doch zur vollständigkeit
immerhin beitragen dass eine
verdoppelung 5 millionen auf 10
millionen ein erheblicher fortschritt
ist für den wir gekämpft haben und
richtig ist dass das haben sie
wahrscheinlich in den koalitionen in
denen sie mitgewirkt haben auch schon
erlebt dass man für dinge im eintritt
und nicht immer auf einen schlag alles
erreichen kann was man möchte und
deshalb ist richtig dass wir das wissen
sie in der union für die erhöhung
eingetreten sind da wir einen wichtigen
schritt gemacht dass wir wie sie ja auch
der meinung sind dass es richtig ist
dass auch länger zurück tragen kann ich
sag's mal mit dem kollegen rolf
mützenich da ist es richtig dass wir
diese fragen gestellt haben wir werden
diese fragen auch weiter stellen
aber ich finde es gehört schon auch dazu
wenn man so eine debatte führt dass man
erkennt wo es fortschritte gibt und eine
verdopplung mit verlaub ist ein
erheblicher fortschritt erzielen
vielen dank herr kollege
[Applaus]
letztere in dieser debatte ist die
kollegen gitta connemann cdu csu
fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
der arme poet kaum ein bild wird so
verklärt der frierende künstler unterm
dach leider inzwischen nicht mehr nur
gemälde sondern realität der
künstlerinnen und künstler haben vor elf
monaten ihre existenzgrundlage verloren
und zwar von heute auf morgen
für sie bedeutet corona dauer lockdown
keine veranstaltung aufführung
ausstellung keine beschäftigung keine
einnahmen diese pandemie trifft kunst
und kultur wie eine naturkatastrophe
individuell aber auch
volkswirtschaftlich denn kultur und
kreativwirtschaft waren von corona kein
aschenputtel sondern ein
wirtschaftsfaktor mit einem stolzen
jahresumsatz von 170 milliarden euro vor
corona der rücklagen hatte hat diese
inzwischen aufgebraucht und zur
wirtschaftlichen not kommt sie ganz
große frage wann dürfen wir wieder auf
die bühne hinter die kamera zu unserem
publikum denn es geht nicht allein um
unsere künstler es geht um uns wir alle
brauchen kultur
denn sie ist systemrelevant und deswegen
verdienen künstler häfen und chancen
genau darauf haben wir reagiert an
erster stelle unsere
kulturstaatsministerin monika grütters
sie hatte die idee für ein einmaliges
programm neustart kultur
es umfasst alle genre in stadt und land
profis und amateure
wir haben monika grütters dabei
unterstützt im sommer mit einer
milliarde und jetzt mit einer zweiten
milliarde für neustadt kultur ohne die
union hätte es diese verdopplung
übrigens nicht gegeben für seine
kreative im koalitionsausschuss danke
ich unseren fraktionsvorsitzenden ralph
brinkhaus
was bedeutet neustart kultur
erstens rettung denn wir helfen bei
einnahmeverlusten und investitionen die
die pandemie erfordert zweitens zukunft
denn wir investieren in strukturen und
digitalisierung meine damen und herren
dabei geht es um mehr als 60
einzelbausteine in windeseile erarbeitet
mit hilfe unserer kultur verbände für
die denen ich im namen von cdu und csu
danke programme für musik galerien
theater tanz literatur buchhandlungen
bibliotheken museen film kinos
soziokulturelle zentren und und und die
programme wurden maßgeschneidert und
kommen an 34.000 anträge 90 prozent der
mittel bereits belegt bundesweit das ist
grandios und mit der zweiten kultur
media.de können wir nahtlos weitermachen
und das ist gut
hinzu kommen gutschein des und für
veranstalter hilfen für kurz befristet
beschäftigte zukunftsprogramm kino und
und und rettung für viele
kultureinrichtungen und damit zukunft
auch für künstlerinnen und künstler
zukunft aber auch für unsere kultur
vereine vom heimatmuseum bis zum chor
denn die ehrenamtlich tätigen
profitieren ebenso von neustadt kultur
hinzu kommt für ehrenamtlich tätige das
bundesprogramm ländliche entwicklung
aber auch hilfen der deutschen stiftung
für engagement und ehrenamt sonst würden
strukturen wegbrechen im ganzen ehrenamt
denn dieses lebt von der begegnung und
wenn diese fehlt löst sich die bindung
und deshalb fördern wir als bund das
digitale miteinander denn wir wissen
jedenfalls als cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion
ohne ehrenamt ist kein staat zu machen
das geht auch für unsere sportvereine
in denen sich über eine million menschen
ehrenamtlich engagieren als vorstände
als übungsleiter mit kreativen ideen
halten sie für 27 millionen mitglieder
auch in der pandemie derzeit
sportangebote aufrecht für jung und alt
und das ist schwerstarbeit
fakt ist mehr als die hälfte von ihnen
verlieren aber derzeit mitglieder und
beim mannschaftssport fielen die
ticketeinnahmen in den ligen deshalb
haben wir ohne helfen auf den weg
gebracht und diese unterstützung kommt
bei den vereinen in der fläche an meine
damen und herren
corona trifft von der kultur bis zum
sport so unterschiedlich sie auch beide
sind beide brauchen hilfe und beide
bekommen hilfe damit wir sie auch noch
nach der pandemie haben denn sie sind
kein ornament sie sind das fundament auf
dem unsere gesellschaft steht deshalb
ist es unsere aufgabe sie zu sichern und
zu stärken und genau dieser aufgabe
stellen wir uns in diesem haus seit
vielen vielen monaten gemeinsam
erfolgreich vielen dank frau coleen
könnte man damit schließt sich die
aussprache